[Music]
that's the 2010 hit tighten up from
possibly the biggest indie rock band to
come out of Ohio the Black Keys the
six-time Grammy winners new album let's
rock will be released tomorrow it's
their first in five years in their only
TV interview Dan Auerbach and Patrick
Carney addressed rumors of their breakup
and tell us what took them so long to
get back in the studio this is the first
song we did breaking down there's a very
first idea we even had when we sat down
it Dan Auerbach and Patrick Carney had
not performed together in three years
when they reunited at easy eye sound in
Nashville last fall when you came in
here to start recording you you had
nothing nothing no no all we had was a
Ouija board a notepad but the simple
approach has always worked for the Black
Keys known for the raw rock sound of
songs like lonely boy and gold on the
ceiling
on their new album let's rock the songs
typically were recorded on just the
second or third tape it feels like every
time we work on something written for
too long it just we we lose it you know
just gets worse is it you lose you think
the magic the thing that you don't have
to think about to get that's the cool
thing power back and Carney started
making music together as teenagers in
Akron Ohio I mean when we first started
Pat was just learning how to play the
drums I was learning how to play guitar
but for some reason we were able to make
things that sounded like music yeah I
really didn't know how to play the drums
through our first show that we played
his drums come just like exploded
everything fell apart like you just
floated their drums and parts everywhere
all over the stage there like washers
flying off knots wing nuts I was chased
hot tasty drums around tickets and I was
singing watching him watching everything
just move away from his body
a gritty GarageBand they recorded one of
their early albums rubber factory in an
abandoned tire plant 600,000 square foot
building it was just us and they're like
we could look through the floor there's
a hole in the floor you can see down to
the the main building and they were like
stacks of tires like wow they're still
tires down there don't even bother
moving them like it was like everyone
just died of cancer one day like the
realities it's like come on in
yeah there's always some weird sentient
cloud just rolling around the second
floor I smoked back then I think I
actually smoked you actually cleaned the
air the Black Keys broke through in 2010
with their album brothers which won them
three Grammys their next album El Camino
won them three more suddenly the indie
band was filling arenas
[Music]
was there a point where the Black Keys
got kind of too big it didn't get too
big it's just we toured too much tor too
hard and and the reason that we did that
was because we spent so long making
absolutely no money you can't say no to
the work and it the shows are a lot of
fun it's addictive the problem is is you
starting gradually this whittling down
like your psyche and what you're able to
the process they finally took a break in
2015 but as it dragged on rumors spread
it was a break-up you haven't spoken to
each other in five years they make light
of it in their latest video go I haven't
heard from them in a while now huh I
heard they hate each other when a
therapist sends them to a spiritual
retreat did you get sick of each other
Edwyn and in that period of time not in
any legitimate kind of way just just the
kind of sick of somebody that you get
sick of anybody if you're stuck on a
boat with them for 15 years yeah you
know I mean my brother's like we used to
beat the crap out of each other
dan and I are more passive aggressive
about it but at some point yeah we
definitely were like it's like not like
we're seeing each other's that we just
you see the space because you you know
it's like yeah you know it's not that we
hate each other we're just sick of each
other's faces yeah just like can't stand
way to the smell you know this fragrance
[Music]
Auerbach spent the past few years
recording a solo album and producing
other acts Carney married and toured
with singer Michelle Branch they have a
new son and Carney's enjoyed the time at
home is the first time in my adult life
like after the age of 21 rest consistent
thing for months able to wake up in the
same bed the Black Keys go back on tour
in the fall but Auerbach and Carney say
their days of epic touring our own
[Music]
we won't do that again well well we
might depends if the if it's like The
Price is Right
[Laughter]
negotiation tour starts in September in
Las Vegas there's only about 33 dates
booked I hope they go longer because
they are a fabulous live band and what
great guys it's so good to see I love
how they say no we didn't really get on
each other we we weren't tired of each
other but you did
I like Pat saying you can't say no to
the work and dancing you know that thing
that happens in magic that you don't
have to do about that they definitely
have that yeah they sure do have I like
that they went from the from a garage
band to filling arenas you can still do
that
who knew there yeah they were almost
unique in that there's not many that
have pulled that off and did you like
let's rock I love this album I think
it's great it's so good to have them
back and it's actually an album you have
this is a white vine it's white vinyl
I'll pull it out that's really cool look
at that yep this is one of the first
ones that came off the press if only you
had a record player yep I do
okay he actually does I don't have to
borrow yours come in any time all right